Rober syndrome is a rare genetic
disorder which affects the development
of cereum
mostly it is inherited in an autosomal
recessive pattern and the symptoms
include hypotonia Ataxia and delayed
motor milestones in babies robot
syndrome can be detected using MRI and
there is classical MRI signatures here
is how a normal brain look like here is
a cereum and one can look at the
cerebelum in Robert patient and it looks
dysmorphic in a horizontal view one can
clearly see there is a molar tooth likee
signature this m tooth likee signature
is due to deep intrapedicular fosa on
the top side and the root of the molar
tooth is basically elongated Superior
cerebral panles this is how the overall
signature look like and there are
several mutations which are associated
with jobber syndrome are displayed here